welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on cell biology of
diseases it's my pleasure to introduce
to you dr. Sergio Greenstein senior
scientist at the Hospital for Sick
Children and professor of biochemistry
at the University of Toronto dr.
Bernstein was an international scholar
of the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
and a recipient of the Medical Research
Council distinguished scientist award
and on the Michael Smith award of the
Canadian Institutes for health research
he is also a fellow of the Royal Society
of Canada for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr. Prince Stein's keynote presentation
is titled phagocytosis macropinocytosis
and the in it immune response recent
advances my name is Michelle Ashton and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots Mavericks is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation simply
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
you are experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Sergio grim
Stein I will now turn the presentation
over to him
hello good morning weather I want to do
today is discuss some aspects of the
innate immune response the one that is
mediated by myeloid cells primarily
macrophages dendritic cells in
neutrophils most of the results and
general mechanisms that I'll discuss
today will relate to macrophages but in
many ways they apply to all other my
heart cells we know primarily about
being maintenance system in the context
of eliminating invading microorganisms
this slide shows invading bacteria in
blue being approached and attacked by a
macrophage shown in yellow the
macrophage is able to recognize adhere
to an engulf and kill the bacteria
eliminating potential pathogens that is
certainly the best known function of
cells of the immune system however we
tend to overlook an equally or perhaps
more important function which is the
role of
phagocytic cells in tissue homeostasis
in each one of us human individuals
approximately 50 to 200 billion cells
die every day they turn over and when
they die they don't go to heaven they
actually have to be buried and the
Undertaker is thermally the mantich
which means that every second
macrophages in our body have to dispose
of five to ten million dead cells and
those two are not the only functions of
energetic cells in the central nervous
system for instance remodelling of
synapses during learning or the process
of forgetting is mediated by a
specialized things in Excel called the
microglia which is really a glorified
macrophage so what is failure sentences
wealthy psychosis refers to the process
of engulfment
this position of particular material
usually greater than half a micron in
diameter because the bacterium it could
be a dead the patent itself receptors
recognize the particle that they were
interested in engulfing in what is
called phase information and once a
vacuole is formed that contains the
target particle that vacuole undergoes
the process that's called maturation
which leads to the degradation killing
degradation and disposal of the material
that has internalized the whole event is
actually receptor mediated and it's key
to recognize properly the target
particles be they bacteria fungi or dead
cells receptors on the surface of the
fingers it Excel recognize ligands on
the particle and because the ligands are
immobilized and because the ligands are
multiple they result in cross-linking
and clustering of the failure cystic
receptors and these receptors signal a
senior's of reactions that is
complicated and very elegant that
ultimately lead to the formation of
pseudopods that extend to engulf the
particle the initial step in general is
thought to be the activation of a
tyrosine kinase usually isarc
family Tiny's subsequently in the
cascade of events are lipid kindnesses
pi3 kinase being an important and just
as a reminder phosphoenol sites are
extremely important very specialized
signaling molecules there are a variety
of different phosphor nasi tights seven
species in particular which are
interconverted by the action
of lipid kinases and phosphatases the
reason why these specialized
phospholipids are important is because
they are recognized by defined domains
or motifs on proteins in the cell and
serve for the recruitment and activation
of a variety of different proteins so as
shown on this slide there are domains
that recognize the FRP and others that
recognize the i-45 p2 etc not only has
it been important to define the binding
domains of these effector proteins but
scientists have actually taken advantage
of this knowledge to identify the
portions of the proteins that recognize
the individual phospholipids excite them
from the target proteins and use them as
probes to detect the presence and
abundance and dynamics of individual
lipids thus one can use a pH domain to
look at pip2 or a px domain to detect
the i3p the way most laboratories have
engineered these domains is by
generating chimeric construct with
fluorescent proteins and so ahead group
of PID p2 or p3 binding being recognized
by a specific domain that is in turn
attached to a fluorescent protein will
be localized in a live cell through
transfection of a plasmid that encodes
for the specific chimeric protein
in the case for instance of pi/3 453 our
laboratory and others have used
extensively the pH domain of a KT a
kinase that's shown to the right in this
flight and absolutely shown in the
following movie expression of the pH
domain of a KT into a macrophage results
in diffuse fluorescence of the probe in
a cell that is not activated but during
the course of the cosine doses as should
be apparent from the following movie
there is an exquisitely localized
transient accumulation of the probe
indicating the formation of pip3
precisely and exclusively at sites where
failures of some are being formed and
the accumulation of the Sherman movie is
transient as the pip3 disappears shortly
after the failure zone sealed using a
similar approach and varying the nature
of the probe that has been used like the
Defiant virtual limits we have come to
learn that individual stages of the
formation of the film are characterized
and in fact driven and signaled by a
particular philosophy so the resting
cell has the IP to which is converted
into pip3 there's generation of PN 3p
and in the late stages of simulation the
pi/4 p and this correlates with the
appearance of specific markers of
individual stages of the maturation of
the field what I've told you so far are
generalities of the process of bingo
cytosis what I want to do now is discuss
two specific short projects in my
laboratory dealing in
case we think of psychosis which as I
mentioned is the process of eating
particulate material the second one as
you will see later it deals not with
eating but drinking by the same cells
the process of macropinocytosis for the
gulping of large volumes of fluid so the
first small vignette that I'll present
his work of a student in male oratory
Philip Ostrovsky who has been studying
the mechanism underlying the engulfment
of particles tearing through psychosis
and as will be shown in the following
movie vo cytosis requires the extension
of pseudo pots that surround and
ultimately engulf the particles this
process is driven by the polymerization
of active what the movie front of you is
showing is the accumulation of in fact
the polymerized form of acting at the
base of the things to become and then
progressing along the pseudo pots as
they travel along the surface of the
target particle and ultimately engulf it
and take it up as I mentioned before the
process is initiated by the
cross-linking of receptors sacrimoni
kinases are an early event I also showed
you that phospholipids are involved but
ultimately the main response is
triggered by the polymerization of
active the mechanical effects are driven
by active and the question that Philip
asked is how close physically are the
receptors from the site where the actin
is polymerized there is no obvious
physical connection between them and it
wasn't clear what the physical relation
between these two events are and so the
question was can we simultaneously
detect the site where the receptor
are being cross-linked inactivated and
the place where the actin is polymerized
in principal mother in techniques of
imaging are sufficiently rapid and
sufficiently of high resolution to
enable us to look at these types of
relationships the unique problem
presented by thingö psychosis however is
that whereas proper microscopic
determinations require the establishment
of a well-defined focal plane
particularly when performing confocal
microscopy in the case of finger
psychosis the three-dimensional nature
of the engulfment process makes it
virtually impossible to track the entire
event as the cells are extending
pseudopods the particle is being driven
into the cell so how do we overcome this
challenge and what we decided to do was
rather than try to keep refocusing the
focal plane was to convince the cells to
perform things I ptosis at a single
focal plane and we accomplish this by
coating the surface of a coverslip ring
a ligand that the cells preferred to
finger cycles namely an immunoglobulin
so what you're seeing in the present
image is a coverslip that has been
homogeneously coated with immigrant
bobbling and the blue circle represents
a macrophage that is being parachuted
from the medium onto the surface of the
glass and in essence what we will be
asking that self to accomplish is to try
to attach an engulf the surface of the
copper slip and indeed these cells have
an enormous appetite and a great ability
to the staff their membranes and they
try to open the big mouth to
eat the entire cover sir what is showing
the next movie is the polymerization of
acting as illustrated before but this
time in two dimensions and you can
imagine yourselves as lying underneath
the cover slip watching upwards the
efforts of the macrophage to open a big
mouth and try to engulf the entire
surface as you can see upon contact
acting polymerizes at the site of
attachment but very quickly the
circumference of the attachment site
increases acting spreads outward should
be obvious you'll notice that not only
does the acting polymerize towards the
periphery but it gradually depolarizes
and disappears from the center of the
fingers in the cup another point to note
is that the structure of the acting as
it migrates outward is [ __ ] it now
this system enabled us to look in a
single focal plane or rather exciting
extended periods of time at the
distribution of active however because
the entire cover silk was covered with
the ligand and the acting was
progressing it was nevertheless
difficult to discern the relative
position of the acting and that of the
receptor so we mainly experiment
somewhat more complicated and perhaps
somewhat more elegant by instead of
forcing the cells to engage we get
spread over the entire surface of the
glass as I showed you in the previous
movie where the result is the opening of
one big mouth AB acting as the cell
endeavors to meet the entire car so what
we did instead was to spot the ligand
using
battery into micro little slot separated
by six microns of uncoated surface and
in essence what we were asking ourselves
to do is not to open one big mouth as
they did in the left panel but to open
many little mouths around each one of
the individual micro patterning spots of
later and what you're seeing on the
panel at the bottom right that is in
fact staining for interacting in green
whereas the distribution of the Lea atom
hence presumably the site where the
receptors were accumulated is shown in
red and in fact if other similar micro
patterning conditions we now detect the
site of accumulation cross-linking and
activation of the receptors which is
shown in blue here and compare it to
actin we can now see on the two inserts
on the right that the area of the
position of the ligand the micro pattern
red spot is indeed where the receptors
lying and where the receptors cross link
can become accumulate that's the top
right whereas the bottom right panel
shows the distribution of active and
what was striking and I think it's
immediately obvious is that the actin is
not particularly polymerized and
accumulated at the very same site where
the receptors are engaged but it's doing
so around them in a halo structure that
is around 1 to 2 microns away from the
site of maximal activation of the
receptors in molecular turns wanted to
migrants is a huge distance so what is
happening and to make a long story short
and what is shown in this particular
series of images is that the site where
the active polymerizes is not where the
micro patterning spots shown in this
case in blue is located but around
and that is an area where integrates
which are appearance receptors become
activated you can see that being
activated integrates shown in red
co-localize much better with the green
actin than does the micro pattern ligand
or the cross-linked receptor just as a
reminder integrins are adhesion
receptors they normally bind
extracellular matrix proteins and they
internally attach the taemin and insulin
which in turn served to bridge the
integrins with the actin cytoskeleton
shown as blue beads in this case we
proceeded to look in greater detail in
the green associated proteins and acting
in the context of frustrated fingers in
doses in this case we use a more
sophisticated type of microscopy which
is step stimulated emission depletion
microscopy to look in more detail at the
relative distribution of actin and the
integral proteins and what you can see
to the left is the mouth open same
pattern in general is observed in the
middle panel for ventolin if you look
now at the panel to the right and if you
zoom into these structures you will
notice a particular arrangement between
the actin which is shown in red and then
jelly which is shown in green vinculum
remember is the protein and associates
with the integrals okay so what do we
know about in the green structure and
it's accumulation on the surface of
cells the best known example is the
formation of focal adhesions which were
familiar with from a variety of cultured
cells and this is
straight in this slide where you can see
aberrant integrins buying into the angel
in entailing which in turn attached to
filaments of active so are we looking in
the case of phagocytosis at focal
adhesions similar to these so I should
be evident from this slide whereas some
of the same proteins are present in both
prototypical focal adhesions and in the
structures formed during frustrated
click aside doses as shown in the left
panels their distribution is not
identical and more importantly there are
a couple of proteins which seem to be
present in the in degree mediated
structures in Pico psychosis that are
not present in focal adhesions and these
are HS one which is a homologue of
court actin and also RBC two which is a
component of the r23 complex both of
them are present in Vega cytosis absent
from conventional focal adhesions so
instead we believe we're looking at a
structure that may be analogous to what
is shown in this other slide Pol isms
photos ohms are structured they're
uniquely found in cancerous cells and
also in some myeloid cells as shown to
the left is a macrophage addressed
adhering to the substratum and to the
right the detail of pathes ohms which
show the integrins tailing and vinculum
but in contrast to a focal adhesion they
form a circle around a pillar of acting
the grunts perpendicular to the plasma
membrane so are we looking in Figure
cytosis at structures there are more
analogous to follow zones and indeed
when you look at all their features
they're extremely similar and both of
them contain ages 1 and both of them
contain arc 2 3
so are we merely looking at the
formation acutely of chromosomes
nearing fingers right doses we decided
therefore to compare the features of
resting Pallas ohms with the structures
that are formed during frustrated Rico
psychosis and as will be obvious from
the following couple of movies running
side by side there are two very marked
differences between the two structures
even though they are superficially
similar the photo sums present
interesting cells remain over very
extended periods of time in the same
general area and their half-lives is
quite long conversely you're in
frustrated think of psychosis there is a
Victorian displacement of the formation
of these photos on mic structures and I
will call them from now on focus on mic
structures as the fingers on all cup or
figures among mouth progresses outward
we quantified the half-life of both
types of Polo's ohms and should be
obvious that those form on breasting
cells have a much longer half-life
they're shown the first two bars
compared to the ones that are shorter
lived in fear of psychosis but perhaps
more striking is the pictorial nature of
the dynamics of formation of the
buddha's own like structures during
favor psychosis which is shown on the
top row and it's contrasted to the photo
zones in the resting cell at the bottom
and if you compare the time shown in
green and the time shown in red fir
figures information you will notice that
there has been a clear Victoria
directional displacement of the process
of mic structures given previous cytosis
whereas in resting cells they generally
remain within the same area and they
turn over much more slowly so structures
are similar but not identical so what
dictates the direction
the Apollo's ohms why is their lifetime
different in the polls and bike
structures different fingers a ptosis
and so we suspected the involvement of
fossil energy lights which is the reason
why I introduced was when also tides and
signaling determinants during phase of
psychosis in the beginning of this talk
so we asked is it known from the
literature whether protostomes required
forceful nos attacks in particular pip2
to test whether columns required the ip2
we engineered cells to express a Hitler
by functional system where a
phospholipase that is able to hydrolyze
the ip2 can be recruited to the membrane
at the time of our choice by addition of
a ligand being molecule called raka mice
organizing will enter the cells will be
bound to a membrane determinants that
have has been transacted and will in
turn recruit active phospholipase to the
membrane at the time of our choosing
upon recruitment the phospholipase will
chew up phosphatidyl inositol four or
five this phosphate or pip2 we can
therefore assess immediately the effects
and the requirement for pip2 on the
formation of pollutants so what is shown
in this image in the top right is a
resting macca fish where you can see
photos ohms formed on the top left of
the cell very distinctly they will
remain there for very extended periods
of time except in the transfected cell
that has a heterodimerization system the
addition bravo Meissen results in the
recruitment of the fossilized
light-based disappearance of pip2
and within seconds complete
disappearance of the protons so these
kinds of experiments taught us that
indeed the
maintenance of collars ohms and possibly
bothersome like structures requires the
presence of pip2 at the metal what is
the faith of pip2 the earning process of
theta psychosis we use the very same
approach that I mentioned before we
utilized a domain of a protein no to
recognize the head group of PRP - may
the chimeric construct with a green
fluorescent protein and expressed it in
cells prior to failure psychosis and
what should be apparent from this pseudo
coloured image where we show a
macrophage in the process of eating a
being shown in as the white circle you
will see that whereas pip2 is present
throughout the rest of the membrane and
the fact that came you leave it near the
base of the failure Civic Cup at the
very bottom the pip2 is beginning to
disappear or has disappeared entirely as
shown by the area pointed to by the
arrow in the slide that is a
three-dimensional face in the event we
also looked at two dimensional events
where we can better control to this
position of the receptors and what is
shown in the panel to the right is a
super color image of the distribution of
pip2 during the course of frustrated
thing cytosis wear blue or cool colors
indicate very low concentrations yellow
and red indicate higher concentrations
and thus should be obvious whereas there
is plenty of pip2 at the edges of the
cell the center of the cell in the
course of frustrated famous high doses
has lost a great deal of the pip2 and
that is perhaps more apparent if you
make an x z or sagittal slice of the
cell is a reconstruction from confocal
images at
you see a resting cell apparent the
glass where there's no phagocytic event
taking place and you can see that pip2
is homogeneously distributed throughout
the cell both dorsal and ventral
membranes are rich in pap to by
comparison the image at the bottom shows
a macrophage enhancing parachuted onto
immunoglobulin and is trying to eat the
coverslip
in the process it has spread much more
widely than a cell that is growing on
uncoated glass but perhaps more
importantly the pip2 at the base of the
cell in the center of the failure silica
has been virtually eliminated and in
contrast to the dorsal membrane there is
practically no pip2 left there is
however plenty to near the edges of
things in the cup and that is precisely
the area where the pissant like
structures remain and so what we believe
is that the disappearance progressively
of pip2 from center of the cup may be
dictating progressive and Victoria
disappearance of follow some like
structures driving in a polarized manner
the formation of the failure zone can we
test that hypothesis well that turns out
to be relatively simple experiment
because there are well described and
quite potent inhibitors of the
phospholipids that is thought to mediate
the disappearance of pip2 during Faygo
psychosis which is social my piece C
gamma a compound called you seven three
one two two has been used extensively to
inhibit the kinase and so what we
question then was what would be the fate
and dynamics of the others of like
structures if we prevented the
disappearance of pip2 and just to remind
you under normal conditions in the
absence of any inhibitors the acting
disappears from the center and
extends around the edges of the finger
city car by contrast in cells that have
been treated with the inhibitory
forceful IPC gamma the phagocytic cup is
initiated the columns form in the center
as well as in the periphery but they
fail to disappear from the center and as
a consequence failure see the cup fails
to expand completely and finger
psychosis is aborted so there seems to
be a directional displacement of cause
of my extraction steering fingers for
ptosis what is the purpose what is the
object and one way to analyze the event
is to use a technique called
interference reflection microscopy in
this technique it is possible to assess
the distance between the plasma membrane
of the cell and the underlying surface
dark areas indicate sites where the
membrane is very tightly opposed to the
substrate lighter areas show a membrane
that is further away and I think the
comparison of the two panels in the
slide in front of you shows that the
area where the both of them like
structures are being generated which are
green on the right panel are those where
the membrane is most closely opposed to
the substrate not only do we think that
the pollutants are pushing the membrane
downwards but we believe that there are
Contractor effects as well what is shown
in the current slide is the distribution
of myosin
around the vago city cup and as we
realized myosin which is a contractile
protein seems to be bridging the pillars
of acting formed by the pitocin like
structures we've ever proposed that
conceivably myosin was inducing a
contractile effect very much like a
earth spring that would help close the
mouth of forming theism around the
target and to test this hypothesis we
collaborated with a group in North
Carolina where we used a transparent and
flexible membrane that was embedded with
little fluorescent articles and content
with [ __ ] for things like doses it can
make a top view of this membrane you
will see that the fluorescent particles
are embedded into the membrane are
fairly homogeneous ly distributed and
the expectation was that should a
macrophage land on top of that membrane
and exert a contractile effect we will
see displacement inward of the
individual fluorescent particles and
this experiments that were done in
collaboration with a group in North
Carolina could be computed and forces
derived from the displacement of the
particles could be converted into movies
like the one that they will see next
where the pseudo color scale indicates
the strength of the forces and the
direction of the arrows points in the
direction where the forces are being
exerted and what this coloring movie
will tell you is that indeed in the
process of light
onto the surface the cells are exerting
a contractile force that tends to close
the mouth of the finger cynic event so
in summary for this section what we
believe is happening during the personal
things I told us is that there are two
types of acting and two processes
ongoing at the same time at the very tip
of the pseudopods acting is pushing
forward and making the face if AKOP
explore and that plans and try to look
for additional liggett's but in those
places where the receptors have already
been engaged then photos of mic
structures like the ones shown in the
preceding slides push the membrane
perpendicularly against the surface of
the particle firming up the interaction
and also tethering myosin that exerts a
contractile force that tends to secure
and close the purse string around the
forming critic cup so this concludes the
first section that I wanted to discuss
that deals with the process of finger
cytosis which is shown in this slide
near the middle in the second section I
want to discuss a related but distinct
process of macropinocytosis because I
ptosis is about eating back up
endocytosis is about drinking and again
cells of the innate immune system are
not only very good eaters for their
constant drinkers they drink like
sailors and they do that because they
want to be sampling the environment to
look for signals of danger signals of
pathogens or antigens that they want to
present the cells of the acquired immune
system so the second section will deal
with work of my colleague dr. Spencer
Freeman and it relates to micropenis
ohms and their fate now in the next
movie I'll show
you that even addressed macrophages are
extending fast pseudopodia and the yet
generally retract but on occasion the
sealed the farm is very large and very
noticeable results that are termed by
Kapinos ohms mechanisms are formed on an
ongoing basis and as a result these
cells sample the medium in prodigious
amounts in fact macrophages are
estimated to drink a volume equivalent
to their entire surface their entire
cytoplasm are me every hour and in the
process internalized the equivalent of
the total membrane surface every 20 to
30 minutes it's a fantastic to turnover
and a great expense of energy there are
two types of micro pinocytosis one of
them is ongoing constitutively as you
saw in the previous movie the other one
is actually exaggerated macropinocytosis
in cells that have been stimulated by
agents such as lipopolysaccharide or
macrophage growth factor in that case
the bank yields formed are even larger
and very obvious to observe by
microscopy what is shown in this slide
are cells at rest to the left themselves
have been treated with much macrophage
colony stimulating factor and you can
see there within minutes there is
formation of very large 3 to 5 micron in
diameter micro penis all these clear
black holes that are seen at both ends
of the cell now the process of formation
of the micro penis ohms is important but
as important or perhaps more so is what
happens why does the theta at this
position of the samples that have been
taken up by macropinocytosis that
wires processing exposure to danger or
inflammation receptors and also transfer
to antigen presenting molecules that all
occurs in the process of maturation of
the mechanism whereby the large module
that's formed is remodeled into more
specialized and smaller structures this
movie that we acquired courtesy of dr.
Robert Parkman and variety sail shows
micropenis ohms labeled with a protein
called sorting nexin and the point of
the movie is to illustrate the extreme
turbulent that occurs spontaneously
shortly after the formation of the
macrocosm which is very telling
regarding this position of its contents
but what you'll see is a huge number and
length of very fine tubules forming as
the size of the overall vacuole
decreases now interestingly we had never
appreciated this but we started thinking
about the conversion of a large vacuum
into small tools and there are very
significant implications regarding the
surface-to-volume ratio of these two
types of structures a sphere such as a
mechanism if it has the three micro
diameter that I mentioned as an example
before would have a surface to volume
ratio of about two to one if that same
sphere is converted into narrow tools
such as the ones illustrated in the
movie which are approximately 50
nanometers in diameter and can be quite
long maybe 10 microns the surface debris
to volume ratio increases dramatically
too
40 to 1 or greater so how does one go
from a two to one service one ratio to
forty to one
well there are two obvious possible
mechanisms one of them is to add
additional surveys but it would seem
very impractical and onerous on the cell
to keep on having huge amounts of
membrane to the already large amounts of
membrane engulfed during
macropinocytosis more conveniently
perhaps more expeditiously and helping
eliminate some of the fluids taken up is
the reduction of volume from the battles
in Indy that can be greatly appreciated
if you load the micropenis ohms with a
fluorescent probe what is shown here are
my Kapinos ohms at two different stages
following the markup in acidic event and
what should be apparent is that over in
the course of just a few minutes the
volume of the mechanism shrinks
dramatically and in the process a
fluorescent marker trapped in its lumen
is concentrated indicating that fluid
has been extracted from the maccabees as
dramatic as the optic of fluid is during
macropinocytosis so is the shrinkage of
the resulting micropenis ohms which in
the long term prevents the swelling of
the cells as the graph to the right
shows you lose about 60 to 70% of the
mechanism within five minutes so if the
volume of the microcosm is decreasing
then that implies that water is moving
out of mechanism and if water is moving
out it must do so driven by the movement
osmotic reactive particles the reason we
chose to study mechanisms is because as
resulting from the uptake of the
extracellular space we know precisely
what is the composition of the lumen in
nascent micropenis on to the extent that
met mechanism resulted from trapping of
a global sample of the extra cylinder
space and because we lifted the
composition of the space we know that
the vast majority of the osmolytes are
sodium and chloride we therefore
hypothesized that in order to shrink the
mechanism sodium and chlorine must be
removed from winning makino zone
followed by osmotically obliged one and
that hypothesis is simple to test in the
case of macropinocytosis because we can
randomly alter the composition of the
extracellular space and we can do that
by replacing Sonya why a large non
permeate cation such as an methyl
ammonium or chloride equally by a large
impermanent organic ano like gluconate
and so we tested three different
conditions
Mike opinion zones formed in sodium
chloride in methyl block ammonia
chloride or sodium glucose the
expectation being that large impermanent
cations would affect the rate and extent
to which the markup in some drink what
is shown in the bottom panels here is
that indeed whereas the sodium chloride
containing mechanism shrinks readily
within a few minutes as we Illustrated
before the absence of an impermeable and
item or the absence of a permanent
cation or the absence of a permanent on
I am prevented the resorption and
therefore the shrinkage of the Makah
penis what I'm showing in these graphs
are collected experiments from a number
of different donors where you can see
that whereas in purple
the control mechanisms shrink very
quickly as I indicated before within
five minutes losing the bulk of their
volume when you don't have sodium in the
medium or when you fail to add chloride
the shrinkage is largely inhibited as
this in the right panel the resulting
concentration of the flourescent Pro
that became greater as water was removed
in the control but fails to happen when
sodium or chloride are emitted from the
solution and so what seems to be
happening is that whoops following the
formation of the large sodium chloride
containing vacuole ions are rapidly
removed from the luminal micropenis that
implies the presence of transporting
systems what transporters could
eventually account for this well maybe
code transporters symporters or anti
Porter's like they are shown in the top
right or perhaps more efficiently
channels that will have a greater
transport number so what do we know
about channels in internal membranes
well not terribly much but we do know
that in the end acidic pathway in
general there are two families of cation
channels they drip channels with the
elantra the trivial family and the tpc
or two pore channels and remarkably by
romantic data shown to the right reveal
that all of these channels are much more
abundant five to ten times more abundant
in macropinocytosis cells themselves
that don't normally affect macrocytosis
so we have several possible covering
channels and one easy way to test for
their involvement is to use pharmacology
and without the labor the point we
tested a series of known inhibitors
my channels to find that the trend Rijn
a blogger of to porn channels was a
fairly effective inhibitor at low
concentrations of the resorption of the
Maccabean Samus shown in the bottom
panel of this slide to the left you can
see that my Cap'n isms have already
Franken after a while and the intensity
of the floor for has increased in the
presence of the trend during the
mechanisms remain and large that the
fluorophore remains dilute so what are
two port channels as the name indicates
they are the result of a genetic
duplication of a channel like structure
they have multiple transmembrane domains
and two poor like structures and germane
to our studies they seem to transport
sodium much more efficiently than they
to other continents like calcium about
20 times more efficiently so our troop
or channel is present in micropenis ohms
there are two kinds of two-port channels
two port channel or TPC one and TPC -
and as shown this slide PBC one is
recruited very promptly to performing
micropenis ohms and remains there during
the duration of their frankish TPC -
which is present normally in later
episodes a compartment is also recruited
although it takes a few more minutes for
it to become a parent of microwaves so
at least anatomically we know that the
channels can be present in maturing Mac
penises whereas pharmacology is
suggestive a more direct way of proving
the involvement of these channels is to
silence their expression in order to
knock out the genes encoding for them
what we're showing in the slides to the
left is a comparison of the extent of
shrinkage of mechanisms in control cells
compared to cells that have been treated
with an SI RNA
the expression of PVC or to port channel
number one and as the collated stay down
the right to illustrate there is a
severe impairment of the shrinkage when
PVC one expression is inhibited
moreover we collaborated with Asia and
ran from University of Pennsylvania who
had generated mice lacking BBC one and
or TBC two and as these experiments show
double knockout mice fail to resorb and
tubing late properly compared to
wild-type animals so we're fairly
confident that sodium transporting
through poor channels seemed to be
required for the remodeling of the
mechanism an interesting feature of the
two-port channels is that they require
the present yet again of a specific
class for emulsified in this case it's
phosphatidyl inositol three five this
phosphate as the graph underneath shows
which is taken from the literature in
the absence of pi/3 fifty two the
channel is virtually inert other
phosphide on sites like p i4 v p2 are
ineffective but in the presence of pi/3
fifty two the channel opens becomes
conductive just as a reminder pi/3 v p2
is a unique endomembrane austrian asset
ID generated by the phosphorylation of
pi/3 p by a kinase called big five the
resulting lipid pi/3 v p2 has been
described exclusively in endomembrane
compartments and so we asked naturally
is the substrate pi/3 p present is the
enzyme that generates pi/3 v p2 namely
big v present and is pi/3 52 itself
generated
makino zone which would seem to be
required for activation of the two poor
channels why the Shan in the leftmost
panel is a pro for the presence of pi/3
P which is clearly very prominent and
generated very early in the formation of
mechanisms prior to the shrinkage the
enzyme that can convert pn 3 p big five
is also recruited rapidly by mechanism
and as suggested by yet another probe
it's conceivable the pi3 5 p 2 it's also
present there and I say conceivable
because there are some questions as to
the reliability of the probe to measure
P f-35b to which present is the only one
available if indeed we need pi/3 552 to
activate the two-port channels and the
two port channels are required for the
shrinkage one would predict that
inhibition of the formation of ti3 5 -
would in turn prevent the shrinkage of
mechanism and luckily there is an entire
family in fact several families of very
potent at specific inhibitors a big
fight we tested the one shown on the
slide and assess the ability of the
mapping zones to resort and as shown in
the bottom left after my communism's not
only failed to shrink but in fact
continue to swell upon addition of the
inhibitors of big fight bringing you
back to the notion that shrinkage of
makino zones is associated with changes
in the surface to volume ratio and that
to violation of the micropenis of seems
to be essential for the processing of
materialism a Kapinos ooh we tested
whether tribulation was indeed prevented
by inhibiting the removal of sodium
chloride from the lumen of the mechanism
and what is shown on the left is a
controlled situation where sodium
chloride was taken up into the mechanism
but is shown to the right is of
mechanism form a medium devoid of sodium
and what you can see is that the failure
of the mechanism to shrink which is
apparent by its size and by a
concentration of the floor part is
accompanied by its inability to tubing
so that the conversion from a sphere to
a tubulin requires the abstraction of
volume and the change in surface the
water ratio and the simulation is
therefore inhibited not only by removal
of sodium but also by the inhibitor of
big-five or by the blocker of the
channel deterrent what's the biological
significance of this whole process well
not only antigen presentation or
delivery of inflammatory mediators to
TLR and other receptors but to the
extent that the entire plasma membrane
is being recycled every twenty to thirty
minutes it is imperative that the
tribulation process be functional to
recycle plasma level components to the
plasma membrane lest they get trapped
inside the cell and indeed we could show
this quite readily by looking at a
memory protein that is known to be
continuously internalized and rapidly
recycled to the membrane in the case of
macrophages when an integral able on the
surface of a normally treated macrophage
the boundary appears on its surface if
however we prevent the shrinkage of the
mechanism by inhibiting big-five or by
other means we find that
whereas the marketing psychosis is
ongoing
the shrinkage stimulation and recycling
are inhibited so that essential plasma
membrane components get trapped in
endomembrane compartments so in summary
we'll have been trying to tell you is
that there are important and ongoing
alterations in the structure of
endomembrane compartments in many cases
vacuums are largely spherical
compartments become tubular and that
that entails changes in the surface to
volume ratio and that the best way to
accomplish that is by removal of water
and volume from the spherical
compartments and that has to be driven
by the preceding movement of specific
osmolytes in the case of mechanisms and
presumably also endosomes sodium and
chloride are the primary osmolytes and
by being transported down the gradients
out of the mechanism are the endosome
into the cytosol they will drag
automatically blanch water with in the
process the membrane will shrink and
interestingly shrinkage of the membrane
generates curvature and that curvature
is required and stabilized by the
binding of proteins that have curvature
recognition domains such as the bar
domains of snakes in the filling or
appetizing proteins and so we believe
that the actual sequence of events is
such that spheres become created
corrugated in little bit simply by
virtue of a loss of volume that is
automatically driven and that induced
small curvature is stabilized and
magnified and enlarged by the binding of
proteins such as part of in containing
proteins that
recognize bind to and stabilize an
extent the tubules that emanate from the
securedoc apartment some in finishing I
just want to acknowledge some the people
in my laboratory in the years that have
contributed to the detection of phosphor
nasi tides in different compartments
fill Ostrovsky for it the work on bones
and like structures Spencer Freeman for
the work of macropinocytosis and their
collaborators and I thank you very much
for your attention thank you dr.
Princeton for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab rooms for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder dr.
Greenstein will follow up with any
questions you submitted via email that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we'll see you next time goodbye